hello and welcome back to khan academy
live sat i'm eric i'm an sat tutor and
one of the sat experts here at khan
academy and today is our third and final
class as a part of this series we've
covered sat math two weeks ago last week
we covered sat reading and today we'll
be on sat writing now if you missed any
of those uh previous classes don't worry
just head to our youtube channel and you
can find the class recording there where
you can re-watch pause fast forward do
whatever you need to get what you want
out of those videos
and if you're joining us for the first
time one quick tech tip to help you get
the most out of this class is to go to
full screen
on youtube and try and up the resolution
to the the best quality that you can
because we'll be going through
real sat writing questions and so being
able to read everything will be really
helpful so uh today's class is on sat
writing so before we dive into the
materials let's take a look at the
topics for today
so first up i'm going to do some
instruction and some practice problems
and so the first thing i'm going to do
is provide a quick overview of the
writing test and share some tips for how
you can mark mark up the test and be
more proactive when it comes to sat
writing questions
next up i'm going to cover subject verb
agreement and do some practice problems
and third i'm going to do go over
sentence punctuation and again do some
real practice problems in the middle
i'll pause for some q a and actually as
i'm going through this writing class
feel free to
throw in any questions that you have as
i'm going along into the youtube chat
and then i'll get to as many as i can in
the middle there and then finally i'm
going to close things out by working
through an sat writing passage and so
this is going to be a 45 minute class
all told and so that's
that's a sneak peek at what is ahead and
so there's a lot of material to cover a
lot of grammar a lot of
writing concepts to learn and so let's
jump into the very first topic
so first a quick overview of the sat
writing and language test so in total
this is a 35 minute section and you have
35 minutes to do four passages with 11
questions each and so what i want to
emphasize here is that means you do need
to move at a decent pace throughout but
you'll notice that every all of these
questions come within passages and so
context is very important and so it's a
bit like the sat reading section in that
the the what comes before and after the
question makes a very is really
important in helping you find the right
answer
so
that's what you'll have to expect and
then in terms of topics and passage
types here's a sneak peek at that and so
you'll have a variety of topics
that fall into a variety of passage type
options
then in terms of the questions that you
can expect to see there are two that i
want to call out the the first are
expression of ideas questions and these
really ask you to improve the
effectiveness of communication and so
that what that means is you know it
might ask you how you might clarify and
add clarity to the passage it might ask
you to
strengthen an argument
um
so it's all about communicating the
author's point more effectively the
second question type focuses on standard
english conventions and this is probably
what you might be more used to seeing
and this is all about grammar
punctuation and
all those great rules that you've
learned in your english and reading
classes in high school
so that's a bit of an overview of the
writing test and now i'll move on to how
you can mark up the writing and language
testing the reason i'm talking about
marking up the writing and language test
is that being proactive is a great
tool not only in math and reading but
also here and so this really helps
engage your mind as you're reading
through the passage and working through
the questions if you are marking things
up and so there are four things that i
would suggest you try the first is to
annotate the passage as you go so this
is
underlining the and
annotating things like the topic
sentence which is the first sentence in
the paragraph uh it's circling things
like but or however these kind of
contrast words that convey meaning
that sort of
thing
the second thing i suggest is that you
underline the question and the answer
choices and why this is important is
that you want to make sure you're
answering the right question and then on
the answer choices what i would call out
is that one word
can make an answer choice wrong
can make a choice wrong make a choice
wrong and so
that this attention to detail and
looking through each answer choice is
really important
third thing i would suggest is to cross
out words to simplify long sentences and
it's all this simplification is the name
of the game and where you'll see this
most often in the writing test
is with something called a prepositional
phrase
and so prepositional phrases
[Music]
start with words like
like
or
above
before so those are a few
things that you want to look out for and
by crossing out prepositional phrases
you can often simplify subject verb
subject verb agreement sentences
it can make it much clearer what's the
subject and what's the verb finally i
encourage you to use process of
elimination and so you can cross out uh
the letter you can cross out the whole
thing uh really the more
the more active you are in crossing out
things that are wrong
the better it is so that you don't use
any more mental energy uh to go through
it
so we'll be get a chance to use all of
these tactics in the practice problems
ahead and in the practice writing and
language passage
so that's a quick overview of what you
might what you can expect on the sat
writing and language section
and a few tips for how you can be more
proactive as you're working through the
passage reading it and doing some
questions now we're going to move on to
some grammar and hopefully some of this
looks familiar to you but if not don't
worry we're going to do a quick review
and then do some practice problems to
reinforce it so let's take a look at the
first concept
so subject verb agreement is topic
number one
now the first thing you want to remember
when it comes to subject-verb agreement
is that a complete sentence or an
independent clause
must always have
a subject and a verb that agree and
the subject as a reminder is the person
place or thing that is doing or being
something and so it is the actor
act that's being
executed
and what you want to remember in terms
of agreement is that singular subjects
always go with singular verbs and plural
subjects go with plural verbs and so
this is the agreement part of the
subject verb agreement and this topic is
one that shows up in so many different
contexts within the sat writing and
language component and so it's worth
refreshing and making sure that you have
a good understanding of what is a
subject and verb what is an independent
clause
also what is a dependent clause
and
a few tips i have when it comes to
approaching subject verb
questions are that you should find the
subject of the sentence first then check
for agreement and so that's
all about identifying the actor
and so in this case the dog is going to
be your subject and the action that he
that the dog is doing
is barking
and so once you know who the actor is it
makes it a lot easier to
to narrow down you know does this agree
or not
the next tip is one that i've mentioned
before and this is around crossing out
unnecessary words to simplify and so
what i mean here is
looking for prepositional phrases that
separate the subject and the verb so the
dog along with the cat was convinced
that it was nap time
so in this case the subject is
any thoughts on what the subject is if
you have a guess go ahead and type that
into the into the text box into the chat
so the subject here
is the dog so it's just the dog
and what i can cross out is this whole
part here along with the cat because
that is a prepositional phrase and a
prepositional phrase is never the
subject so prepositional phrase
prepositional is such a long word so i'm
just going to abbreviate it and so the
dog was convinced that it was nap time
and so in this case i've identified that
and so then we have the verb here
was convinced
and so there you have it
so this is these are
some quick refreshers of what subject
verb agreement is all about and you
might be thinking okay i got it i got it
let's get to some practice problems well
i agree so let's do some practice
problems apply what we've discussed
about being proactive in marking up the
answers and the questions
and keeping all of these things in mind
but before that i want to throw a few uh
questions and pronouns your way to test
you know what is singular and what is
plural so let's take a look
so subject verb agreement
are these phrases singular or plural and
so we're going to step through each one
of these and as i'm going through if you
think you know the answer go ahead and
type that in and then i'll i'll share
the answer in why that is so he or she
is it singular or plural
so that one is singular and that one is
you know more straightforward it's an
individual it's referring to he or she
and so that one is more straightforward
but what about this next one anyone or
each one
anyone or each one is that singular or
plural
so that one is also singular
and that's because this is what is
called an indefinite pronoun
and it's one of those
uh
one of those
parts of the english language where it
actually will be helpful to memorize you
know what ver what pronouns fall into
this category because indefinite
pronouns are always singular even though
they might uh sound like they're
referring to multiple or uh many people
so that one is also going to be singular
what about we
singular or plural
so this one is going to be plural
and so we is referring to multiple
people
and so that one you know probably makes
makes sense
now what about this next one of everyone
and every or every body is that going to
be singular or plural
and some of y'all might be thinking well
is it the one am i thinking about the
one and it should be singular or am i
thinking about the every because then
that's talking about lots of people
so singular or plural
this one is also going to be singular
and this is an indefinite pronoun again
and so this is another example of where
you know memorizing that this is a an
indefinite pronoun will help you uh with
subject-verb agreement questions and
making sure that they you pick the verb
choice that agrees now what about
somebody
somebody singular or plural
that is also going to be singular so
again we have this indefinite pronoun
and so um you know you're spotting the
pattern here and so i'll move on to the
next one the turkey as well as the
chicken
turkey as well as the chicken singular
or plural
so this one is yet again singular so
turkey is the subject here and as well
as the chicken is actually a
prepositional
not a prepositional phrase but
it does not create a compound subject um
and so all of this the only subject in
this sentence is going to be that is
going to be the turkey now last one the
james and i
singular or plural
so this one is finally plural and the
reason for that is and is a conjunction
in that
and creates a
compound subject and that compound
subject involves two individuals and
that is james and i and so that is why
that is going to be plural
so now we've done some of that to kind
of really give you a refresher of some
of those trickier pronouns
and now we're going to do a practice
problem and so here's where you know if
you weren't in full screen before it'll
really help so that you can read the
read the text and read the question so
let's take a look uh practice question
number one billy although he had a great
sense of timing for stand-up comedy
were handicapped by his poor memories so
billy although he had a great sense of
timing for stand-up comedy
were handicapped by his poor memory and
so what i want to do here is i want to
find the subject
what is the subject
so that subject is going to be
billy
and so this is going to be singular and
were is actually plural and so we have
an issue here and so this should be
billy was handicapped by his poor memory
and so we have answer twice see there
and so that does not work uh billy have
been handicapped by his poor memory is
incorrect and where being handicapped
again does not agree uh given the tense
and the uh singular nature of the
subject there
so uh that was a
that was a good warm-up question let's
keep going to the next one
so with the help of the matsu regional
medical center middle school students in
gateway alaska observe intubation and
sets bones
so with the help of the matsu regional
medical center middle school students in
gateway alaska observe intubation and
sets bones
so what what do you think is the subject
here because that is again my
the first step that i would take is i
would think about what the subject is
the subject here
is going to be middle school students
and what is the action that they're
doing
so here is observe intubation and sets
bones and so
this one
the question actually helps you out here
because this observe intubation
is not underlined and so that part has
to be has to be correct you can't change
it and so you have to assume that that
is a given and so this verb is it
singular or plural
students observe
well i've got students here
subject this is the subject
students there and so this is plural
students observe and what about sets
bones
so there
that is actually singular and that is
not correct it does not agree with this
subject which is plural
over here and so this should be
middle school students set bones and so
there i have it answer choice d
and then all of this is a phrase that i
could that i can cross out so with the
help of the matsu regional center that
is not part of the subject and so it's
fair for me to ignore that to simplify
uh the sentence and just focus in on the
plural subject that i have here and the
in and the verbs that i have here
great so those were two of our three uh
subject verb agreement questions and now
we're gonna do one final one um to get
some extra practice and then we'll move
on to the next concept and do some q a
and then do the writing passage with
questions so let's keep on going
okay so adventure climbers like alex
honold specializes in free solo ascents
without ropes up sheer cliff faces such
as el capitan and yosemite national park
so adventure climbers like alex honold
specializes in free solo ascents without
ropes of sheer cliff faces
so what do you think is the subject in
this sentence
so
we have
you know some of you might be thinking
it is climbers
some of you might think it's alex honold
and so actually let me uh i'll mark
those in a different color there
climbers or alex honold
now which one do you think it is
well
it's actually going to be
climbers
so your subject is climbers and the
reason for that is
this phrase like alex honold
is one of those prepositional phrases
that i mentioned so prepositional
phrases and prepositional phrases can
never be the subject of a sentence and
so in this case it is just climbers
specializes in free solo essence and so
specializes is going to be your verb
here
so we've got subject there and that's
going to be plural
subject
so plural and then specializes that
singular or plural climbers specializes
so specializes is incorrect it should be
special lies
um so we got to take that off
and so there is going to be our answer
answer choice c and so
you know the rest of this sentence is
great so free solo ascents in el capitan
and yosemite great places it's a you
know great national park you should go
if you haven't been
but it doesn't really matter for the
grammar and uh accuracy of the sentence
and so if you just focus in on the
subject and the verb and just cross out
prepositional phrases and focus in on
climbers here and specializes it really
helps to simplify
the sentence and focus in on what the
error is and what you'll notice is
i've been doing something interesting
here in these practice problems in that
i have you know dissected the sentence
by looking at the subject and then i
figured out you know is this right or
not
right or not
and then
i've if it's you know been wrong i've
asked how would i fix
how
to fix
and with that it makes it a lot easier
to figure out you know is it no change
is it b is it c is it d and so knowing
the graph
if it's grammatically correct or not
predicting how to fix it and then
matching to the answer can really help
so
those are the subject verb agreements
questions that we have
for today and now i'm going to move on
to sentence punctuation and in
particular within sentence punctuation
and this really builds off of the
subject verb agreement that we've
started out with because uh
subject and verbs so a complete
independent clause will have a subject
and a verb and what we're about to get
into how you connect independent and
dependent clauses depends all on your
ability to figure out is this you know a
complete sentence by itself or not so
hopefully you're joining
us midway feel free to you know back up
and uh watch and you'll you'll catch up
eventually um so let's look at sentence
punctuation next which is another really
common topic that you'll see on the sat
writing
so sentence punctuation and
so let's take a look the first two
pieces of punctuation i'm going to look
at are the semicolon and the period and
these as a refresher are used to
separate two independent clauses that
each have a subject and a verb and so
that's the definition of an independent
clause or complete sentence you want to
have a subject and a verb
and so an example here is yoda can read
minds semicolon i hate playing card
games against him and so i'll just make
this very clear and so this is an
independent clause here and this is
another independent clause here
now
the next piece of punctuation is the
comma and the conjunction
and so these are used to join clauses by
converting one clause into a dependent
clause and so an example sentence here
is george lucas is a creative genius
comma
but episode 3 was not his best work and
so that's a comma and a conjunction
and so this is going to be your
independent clause
and then this is going to be your
dependent clause there
finally i have the dash and the
semicolon and these are used to
introduce a list quote or explanation
and what you want to remember is that
the part of the sentence that comes
before
the dash or the colon must be an
independent clause
so an example here is star wars movies
always start with the same phrase
colon
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
and so this first part is an independent
clause
and so that it that's what makes this
semicolon correct and in case you can't
tell already i'm a big star wars fan so
hopefully these sentences were uh
weren't too agonizing for for you so
that's a quick refresher on a few of the
most important types of punctuation that
you want to
know how to work with and interact with
on the sat writing and language test now
we're going to do some practice problems
to apply what you've learned and see
what it's like in context
okay so again if you're just joining us
you'll want a full screen
just so you can read the read the
question and the sentences more easily
so president thomas jefferson had one
slightly unusual dream
he hoped to find a living woolly mammoth
in the western united states so
president thomas jefferson had one
slightly unusual dream he hoped to find
a living woolly mammoth in the western
united states okay so what i want to do
here so i'll just emphasize that that
that's a comma
is figure out what kind of clauses i am
connecting so this is you know clause
number one and this is clause number o
two and so clause number one is that an
independent or a dependent clause
so does it have a if it's independent
it's gonna have a subject and verb by
itself and be able to stand alone
so hopefully you said that that was an
independent clause
and then what about the second one he
hoped to find a living woolly mammoth in
the united in the western united states
so that one's also an independent clause
and in this case
which type of punctuation do you think
works here is it going to be no change
a colon
semicolon
or a dash
[Applause]
so in this case it's going to be answer
choice
b because the second part of this
sentence is connects directly to the
first and explains what uh
jefferson's unusual dream was and so you
can
it logically follows and it is the first
part of the sentence introduces the
second part
which explains the dream that he had
and so
that is going to be your answer choice
there and you'll notice that i'm writing
b in big block letters and the reason
for that is that writing this out makes
it faster to transfer answers to the
bubble sheet so faster bubbling
and it reduces the chance of a careless
mistake reduces the chance of a careless
mistake
that is bubbling in the wrong answer and
carrying the wrong one over
chance of careless mistakes
great so that was one example let's keep
on going to the next one
so this year's shark week
on the discovery channel features the
rarely seen sharks of the cuban coral
reefs
footage includes in water and on water
activities with sharks and in case it's
hard to see that is a semicolon
so this year's shark week and so here
again this first clause is it
independent or dependent
going to be an independent clause
and then footage includes in water and
on water activities with sharks what
about clause number two does it have a
subject and verb and can it stand alone
yes it can so that one is also going to
be an independent clause and so you have
two independent clauses that are related
and what are the ways to connect two
independent clauses well we've got the
period or we've got the semicolon or um
we could do a comma and conjunction
and so let's see which one would work
best here
um well semicolon that that checks out
reefs colon
footage includes in water and on water
activities that's i'll keep that one
that's a possibility
semicolon and
no so if i have a semicolon that
connects two independent clauses enough
and then reefs comma
well a comma by itself does not work
because it's it needs a conjunction to
be able to connect to
independent clauses like that
so that is out and so you're down to two
and
uh so in this case i'm gonna go with the
answer choice a and the reason i
a is correct is that um this footage
actually
does
so one is that these are two independent
clauses and the second reason is that
this footage
doesn't tie directly back to the
rarely seen sharks
directly and so
this
no change and semicolon does the best
job of connecting the two clauses but in
this case you know i would have had had
to ponder a little bit about this um but
in this case you know the semicolon
doesn't does the cleanest easiest uh
clearest job of separating these two
independent clauses and so uh question
it's going to be answer choice a there
so
this is the last question but before we
get to the last question
i want to emphasize a few things about
the approach i've been taking and so
as you'll see with these
sentence punctuation practice questions
i've been really focusing on figuring
out what kinds of clauses am i
connecting am i looking at an
independent and dependent independent
and independent
clause and as you practice more you'll
get better and faster at identifying
what kinds of clauses you're dealing
with and therefore what kind of
punctuation would make the sentence
grammatically correct then similarly to
before once i know what i'm working with
i ask myself
is this correct or not and if not how
would i fix it and with that in mind i
can then
get to a the final answer much more
quickly so this last one is a bit longer
and so get ready but don't worry you
follow all the exact same processes and
like i mentioned before if you have
questions feel free to add them into the
youtube chat and i'll answer them
shortly
so last one
contrary to the popular
perception that dna was watson and
crick's discovery
semicolo
colon rather
its helical structure and phosphate
backbone were first recognized by a
woman
and that one is a semicolon
the english chemist rosalind franklin
so i've got three clauses here contrary
to the popular perception that dna was
watson in quick discovery this is clause
number two and i've got clause number
three here
and so
what am i working with with clause
number one
so that's going to be a dependent clause
so i don't have a the reason i know that
is one i
the clause starts out with contrary
and i don't have a subject there
so then what about number two it's
helical structure and phosphate backbone
were first recognized by a woman
is that an independent or dependent
clause does it have a subject complete
subject and verb and can it stand on its
own
so that one is a perfectly fine uh
complete sentence and so that's going to
be an independent clause and what about
number three the english chemist
rosalind franklin
so i definitely have a subject there but
i don't have a verb and so that's going
to be a dependent clause
and so now
in terms of connecting this dependent
and independent clause
what about this this first clauses 1 and
2.
well i've got a dependent and
independent and so
and i have a conjunction here
and so i think a comma will serve me
quite well there so contrary to the
popular perception that dna was watson
and crick's uh discovery comma its
helical structure and phosphate backbone
were first recognized by a woman
and so that's an independence and a
dependent clause
so can i connect these two
can i connect an independent and
dependent clause with a semicolon
you cannot
but
uh i could use a
colon here since this the english
chemist rosalind franklin is explaining
who this woman
is
and this we mentioned was an independent
clause and so i want to look for an
answer that has a comma and a semicolon
and so
discovery comma
its helical structure and phosphate
backbone were first recognized by a
woman semicolon so that's out we said
that that was wrong so comma and
semicolon
boom
there is my final answer
so as you saw i kind of broke down all
of the clauses here and then figured out
how what i needed to correctly connect
all of them
and so
that question was a little had a little
more text involved was a little trickier
but if you kind of
break down the sentence piece by piece
be really active as you go through it
you can really
simplify and
even if it looks complicated at first
you can get to the right final answer so
now i'm going to do a few
uh questions and
uh before i jump into the the
the writing passage so if you have
questions feel free to
throw them in there into the chat and
i'll get to as many as i can
let's see
is it necessary to read and annotate
parts of the passage that have no
questions directed to them great
question and you know that you're
probably thinking well if there are no
questions underlined in the if there are
no questions in that part of the passage
do i need to pay as much attention and i
would actually say the answer is yes and
the reason for that is that there are
questions in the sat writing and
language test that depend on the context
and almost all of them actually depend
on the context and in particular
questions like should you add or delete
this sentence or sentence seven should
best be placed where all of those
questions rely on the context of the
paragraph and of the of the passage and
so if you've skipped over or kind of
glossed over those parts you won't have
that critical piece of information that
will actually
help you answer the question about
adding or deleting a sentence moving a
sentence so on and so forth so
absolutely you um you should definitely
be paying attention even if the part of
the passage isn't underlined as
you know having a question about it
um okay how do you suggest we practice
how to speed our test taking pace
um so there are a few things i would
suggest there the first would be to go
on khan academy official sat practice
and after you finish three writing
evidence-based reading and writing
practice sessions you'll be able to
unlock a timed mini section and so these
are
timed 11 question writing or reading
passages
where you know on khan academy the timer
will tick down and so that's a great way
to pace yourself through one passage the
second way i think i would suggest you
practice your timing and pacing is by
doing a full-length practice test
and if you know you find that you mainly
have problems in the writing section it
can be you know fine
practice those full writing sections
have a timer you know kind of calculate
if you have 35 questions and four
passages 35 divided by four is going to
be roughly nine minutes per passage and
so that can be a good mental model and
so practicing that pacing from start to
finish would be the second way that i
would do it and so the more practice you
have with the real timer
the better and faster you're going to be
um let's see
[Music]
how should we write our essay like what
format would be best maybe a five
paragraph essay so great question and so
when it comes to the essay i wouldn't
focus
uh purely on the the structure i think
if you're comfortable with a five
paragraph essay and you've gotten used
to that in class that is completely okay
to use but what you want to focus on
with the sat writing and language essay
is to really
to not restate what the author is saying
because every sat
right essay prompt will focus will ask
you to
dissect how the author makes his or her
argument using
evidence using persuasive elements and
stylistic elements and so you really
want to focus more on ho on answering
that prompt and saying and articulating
how what pieces in the author's writing
reinforces his or her point and how that
is is done in the essay and you can
actually go and practice
writing an essay on official sat
practice and we have an essay practice
where you can do some pre-writing do
some writing and then we'll actually
generate a score for your essay
to tell you where your strengths and
weaknesses are
so that's all the time we have for
questions now and so i'm going to jump
over to doing uh
the practice passage
and so we're going to go through as many
questions as we can before we wrap up
and so let's take a look now at
the context of a real sat writing
passage
okay
so again here it will be really
important to zoom in as i'm reading the
passage so the political power of first
ladies
a high-profile unelected official with
the political resources to influence
domestic policy the president of the
united states has a wife
known as the first lady
known as the first lady occupies a
unique position many first ladies not
content with simply playing a role of
dimir wife and social hostess have taken
an active role in the political sphere
and i'm going to go back there
even though her power comes by way of
marriage rather than from the electorate
or constitution the first lady or first
gentleman has a responsibility to
capitalize on her situation and attempt
to create significant lasting change
if the president of the united states is
female her husband's title would be
first gentleman
throughout u.s history there have been a
number of influential politically
engaged first ladies from whom future
first ladies or gentlemen can take
inspiration
great so
we're talking about first ladies and
first gentlemen and their obligation to
be politically engaged and create
positive change and i've started the
first and last sentence because those
are uh tend to be really important to
helping me understand the the passage so
abigail adams the second first lady in
american history was first to assume a
protruding role in the political sphere
unlike her predecessor martha washington
adams was outspoken well educated and
quickly developed a reputation of a
staunch partisan defender after openly
criticizing congress for not declaring
war on france in 1798.
her influence is so well known that
opponents claim the president refused to
make any appointments without her
approbation
and it's and aspiring politicians sought
her endorsement
in recent years adams has become a
popular topic for biographers because of
her thoughts on gender slavery and
politics
okay so we've we're talking about
abigail adams here in the second part
and her achievements and so we'll just
read to that point for now because of
time and we'll tackle the first question
here and i'll zoom in a little bit more
so that you can see it so question 1 of
11.
and so you might be wondering well what
is the question well this is what's
called a stemless question
and what you want to do here is go back
to and find the number one in the
passage which is right here
and with that
see if
determine whether you would make no
change or if there is a change that
would need to be made to either
strengthen the communication in the
passage or fix a grammatical error so if
you recall we started this session by
saying you know those are the two main
types of questions you can get and so
let's look at question number one we'll
read some of the context and see so
high-profile elected official
with the political resources to
influence domestic policy the president
of the united states has a wife known as
the first lady occupies a unique
position
so can any of you
uh so first question is there an error
or not
so hint there is an error so it is not
no change but can any of you spot what
the error is in in number one
it is what's called a modifier error
and what that means is that we're
talking about the first lady here
um so
a highly profile unelected official
that's the first lady and then we also
followed up with known as the first lady
and so what's odd here is that we have
all of these phrases about the first
lady and then number phrase one says the
president of the united states has a
wife well um all modifiers should be
placed very close to
as close as possible to what the object
they're describing
for clarity because in this case we're
talking about the first lady but then
we have the president right here and so
it makes it confusing are we talking
about the first lady or are we talking
about the
the president and so in this case the
way you would correct this
is with answer choice d because it
focuses on the wife of the president of
the united states and then whereas in
the enhancer choices c united states
president has a wife we're again
focusing on the president um and then
and answer choice b we're talking about
the united states which is not even a
person and so this is uh
the error here is a modifier placement
error and so answer choice d clarifies
that by
let's take
coverage the first lady has a
responsibility to capitalize and create
significant lasting change
and then if the president of the united
states is female her husband's title
will be first gentleman throughout
history there have been a number of
influential and politically engaged
first ladies from whom future first
ladies or gentlemen can take inspiration
so the first question you want to answer
is should this be kept or deleted
because if you look at the answer
choices here we've got two keeps and two
deletes and so if you can make that
decision uh it you know cuts out half of
the options and what i like to ask
myself here is you know does the does
sentence number two
does it add
uh something meaningful um or not um is
it repetitive
and does it add relevant information
and so those are some of the questions
that i like to ask myself when i make
this decision and so we have if the
president of the united states is female
her title will be first gentleman and so
to me that is an interesting point but
it's also something that we have here
first lady or first gentleman so we
mentioned it so it is repetitive so
that's one strike for deleting it
and then the next thing i want to ask is
you know is it relevant
so
it does relate to the passage but
here we talk about creating significant
lasting change
and then in the last sentence there have
been we talk about influential and
politically engaged first ladies and you
know making an impact and so
it's not super relevant to making that
point of lasting change in political
impact and so
that gives me confidence that we should
not keep it and so
here we have deleted because it
interrupts the introduction of the
passages main argument with a loosely
related detail
deleted because it weakens the passages
influence on the importance of work done
by several several influential first
ladies
well
c is the closest to
what i was discussing because it does
interrupt the main point
and it is a loosely related detail but
not significant
great so now let's look at number three
which choice is most consistent with the
writer's position as established in the
passage
most consistent so
this if we look back at
number three abigail adams the second
first lady in america was first to
assume a protruding role so we're
looking here
unlike her predecessor adams was
outspoken well educated
and quickly developed a reputation as a
staunch partisan defender
and so this is uh all pretty
positive so
a protruding role and so this is
essentially
a
way of asking you know what does
protruding mean in context or what might
substitute within
for protruding so i'm going to say a
influential role would be my guess
influential
and so let's see which one matches that
most consistent with the writer's
position and so the writer's position
actually um this question is actually
not asking you know what would could go
in place of number three but what most
fits within the author's
meaning and intent of the re within the
rest of the paragraph and it's pretty
positive influential and it's a pretty
positive regard so protruding
is that uh
does that mean influential and positive
well sort of protruding means kind of
standing out but it has a bit of a
negative connotation so a bit negative
and so i don't think it's that but i
won't cross it off yet and then what
about obstrucive and obstrucive one
so again let's say maybe you didn't know
what that meant and so i'll skip that
for now what about a prominent one
prominent does mean influential and it
is pretty positive so that one has two
checks in its favor an ostentatious one
ostentatious say
yeah
so this one uh
also does not fit but say you didn't
know what that meant and you only had
this to go off of well in this case
you should always guess because there is
no guessing penalty and so even if you
have it down to this and you're thinking
well maybe this one isn't it so go ahead
and cross that out and then you're left
with these three if you're getting a
pretty strong signal
from the smiley face and two checks that
this does fit with the writer's position
with regard to abigail adams then go
ahead and select c
and in that case you would have been
right because an obstrusive obstrusive
actually means something very similar to
protruding so it's kind of sticks out
but
kind of in a negative way
and then ostentatious is another word
that kind of means braggy or showy
and so it has some negative connotations
and so that would have been out as well
so i'll do
one more question and then we'll wrap it
up because of time but let's take a look
so number four
so this is a stemless question again so
i want to look at question number four
should it be changed uh or not
and so let's see
she had a protruding rule
and
her influence is so well known that
opponents claim the president refused to
make any appointments
without her approbation and aspiring
politicians sought her endorsement and
so this is a verb um and so her
influence is so well known is this uh
is any change needed is there any kind
of grammatical error
um at all
well i think there is because if you
notice
the tenses of the rest of the sentence
are claimed in the past tense refused in
the past tense
sought in the past tense yet is is in
the present tense so i think what would
fix this is uh
was and so
her influence was so well known
that all of these politicians helped her
and admired her
great so
that is a glimpse at
what the sat writing and language
section looks like within the context of
a real passage and what i want to
emphasize
there is that the context of the passage
so all of the parts before and after the
underlying portions are very important
for you to
pay attention to because they inform the
answer of all of the
questions that you're prompted and what
you need to look into in the underlying
portion and so i know we didn't get
through all of it but
if you want more practice with this
passage
on those like it go to official sat
practice and do those practice sessions
either untimed if you're you know just
starting out or do them timed so that
you can simulate the real uh situation
now the last thing i'll share with you
is an sat badge a khan academy badge for
attending this class and so go ahead and
look in the chat room
and we'll be sharing a link to a badge
that you can get for attending this
class and what you'll do is click on the
link
head to khan academy and then uh log in
and once you log in you'll see in the
top right hand corner of your screen a
notification pop up that says hey you've
got the khan academy sat writing badge
and so
i'll leave you with that and then uh for
those of you who are taking the sat this
saturday um a few tips i would share is
you know just to relax ahead of the test
don't stress out don't try and cram 10
practice tests beforehand
what's most important right now is you
know really getting
enough rest eating well and preparing
all the materials and admission ticket
and pencils that you need for test day
don't try and do any crazy cramming
before saturday because they're uh you
know you've just got a few days left and
it can often be counterproductive to
stress yourself out on khan academy in
our tips and strategies section we also
have a number of articles for what you
should be doing the week before and the
day before and how you can get ready uh
in those last 24 hours so
if you're taking the test this saturday
best of luck to you and for those who
have been with us over the course of the
these three classes i hope this has been
helpful for you um and i know it's been
fun for me and for all of us at khan
academy so thanks so much for for
joining us and
we might see you again in the future
take care
you